the sex trafficking conviction of
galaine maxwell faces a new challenge
this morning
maxwell's attorneys say they are seeking
a new trial after a juror gave media
interviews where he said that he himself
was a victim of sexual abuse another
juror later made a similar statement now
last week jeffrey epstein's former
girlfriend was found guilty on five
different charges mola lenghi explains
why the juror's actions could now be a
big problem
glenn maxwell's sex trafficking
conviction is now anything but done new
doubts about whether her trial was fair
over comments by jurors in recent media
interviews two jurors say that sometime
during the five days of deliberations
they revealed that they themselves were
sexually abused in the past former
prosecutor moyra penza that juror could
face criminal penalties if it was found
that he purposely misled the court that
would absolutely be grounds for a new
trial at issue is whether or not the
disclosures were made during jury
selection before the trial potential
jurors were asked to fill out this
questionnaire including this question
have you ever been the victim of sexual
assault one juror using only his first
and middle names scotty david told
reuters he can't remember if he
disclosed his own claims of sex abuse
saying he flew through the initial
questionnaire he told reuters he would
have answered the questions honestly
prosecutors told the judge overseeing
the trial the statements merit attention
by the court
maxwell's lawyers then told the judge
she can and should order a new trial a
separate juror told the new york times
they spoke of their own sexual abuse
during deliberations which the paper
says appeared to help shape the jury's
discussions
anyone would say that having to retry a
case would be a benefit to the defense
they will have seen how the prosecution
has already tried their case for cbs
mornings i'm mola leggy
it's a very interesting turn the juror
known as scotty david is now represented
by a lawyer appointed by the court we've
reached out to that attorney for comment
we've not heard back the judges set
dates where both sides could request a
new trial asking them to address whether
an inquiry into the matter is permitted
or even required my thoughts are with
those survivors who might have to relive
that trauma let's not forget that you're
right